and finally new rule let's use Father's
Day to ask Republicans how the daddy
party went from these guys to this guy
yes sunday is Father's Day and it
reminded me that political wonks and
pundits have always referred to
Republicans as the daddy party Democrats
they were the mommy party the nurturers
the caretakers the compassionate ones
Democrats worried about your health care
and education and Republicans are all
about security and fiscal responsibility
and they used to take their role very
seriously the no-nonsense keep you safe
pay the bills party but Republicans
really aren't the daddy party anymore
they're more like the absentee father
party
going through the midlife crisis making
bad decisions with all this pretend
confidence it's like the entire parties
wearing a toupee under Trump they've
become the deadbeat dad party the dad
who spends money we don't have and who
blows the family budget on stupid [ __ ]
like a wall we don't need
this dad hangs out with the wrong crowd
alien eights the neighbors Canada and
Mexico we used to get along great with
them and now they bring the kids inside
when they see is coming and what kind of
dad doesn't keep up with routine repairs
you know you're a president who's let
the place go when your wife has had more
work done than the roads and the bridges
and this is not a personal attack on
Trump as an actual father he clearly has
a supportive loving relationship with
one fifth of his children but someone
has to explain to me why at Trump
rallies it is a common refrain to hear
that Trump is the strict dad American
needs they really do see him as a father
figure you know strong but quiet strict
but fair man who gets up in the morning
puts on two pounds of concealer
inflates his hair and spends the day
tweeting like a mean girl
Atticus Finch meets fattest [ __ ]
back when Milo was the thing he used to
literally call Trump president daddy but
he's hardly the only one who sees Trump
that way Jerry Falwell Jr said of Trump
he reminds me so much of my father yes
because they're both con men Kanye West
thinks Trump is the father he never had
you know my dad and my mom separated so
I didn't have a lot of male energy in my
home it was something about when I put
this hat off and made me feel like
Superman well of course he loves Trump
he's a sucker for a giant ass
[Applause]
[Music]
but as for those of us just trying to
survive in this American family we have
to come to terms with the reality that
the daddy party is the [ __ ] dad party
now and the patriarch of it all is a hot
mess and you know what happens when
daddy's a useless piece of crap right
mom has to take over and that's why
Democrats they're no longer the mommy
party they're the single mother party
they're the party that has to work two
jobs because daddy went out for
cigarettes and never came back
the single mother party now was the only
one that cares about the kids future the
Republicans they're the other party of
the Koch brothers pollute all you want
now because tomorrow
not our problem we'll be gone when Trump
was in England last week he was amazed
at Prince Charles's concern for the
planet and its longevity he is really
into climate change and what he really
feels warmly about is the future what a
weirdo
caring about the future boy bill Barr
was recently asked about his legacy does
not care he said I'm at the end of my
career everyone dies
Rudy Giuliani said the same thing I
don't care about my legacy I'll be dead
which is shocking I thought he was dead
so happy Father's Day but keep in mind
if Republicans made a commercial for
life insurance it would go like this you
love your family but if you what if you
weren't there to take care of them oh
well [ __ ] happens
you